do something isn't it this nice what
explaining people what goes on in a
party like this people don't understand
how monument is this occasion is we all
flew down here put on our good clothes
because this is just a great occasion
this is going to be a magnificent even
there's gonna be eating there gonna be
drinking there's a few tears there's
gonna be great performances tyler has
people he won't need to tell us who it
is right so you know it could be brewing
on Mars it could be Beyonce anybody
that's what my money's on cuz I saw
Kelly and Michelle here could be anybody
the nice thing is it's a safe place you
know it's just gonna be a great
celebration tonight I agree I can't wait
to get in there by the way what in the
world happen with blac Chyna explained
real quick what in the world happened
well blac Chyna I'm gonna tell you I
believe blac Chyna just got scared she
was there and she never put her clothes
on she just she had her makeup on she
did get there hour and a half late but
we tried to stretch out we stretched out
one segment and then it was like okay is
she gonna come for the last segment and
she couldn't make it
and I just think she got scared we're
the type of show that we're very safe
but it's also live you have to remember
a lot of people not used to doing live
so I just think she got scared and so we
are inviting her back and we haven't
pre-taped and she can just be calm and
everything no so y'all are doing your
show and you're all in the set and
you're like we're waiting on blac Chyna
to come out she's coming out right she's
coming out y'all right we we've
formatted the shows for her
now we'll point are y'all really angry
because if someone messes with your show
like that somebody had to get really you
know being alive so we are always
prepared we have segments backup
segments at what point were people like
we're getting really mad that she is
doing this
you never got mad
we never got met can't we've never got
mad okay no man it was more of a concern
because of something that's happening
where she's there and she's not getting
dressed we don't know why and then I
just say oh it's because she was just
frightened and you know it the only
thing is that it is a concern because
people lost you know that could have
been a spot for someone else to promote
something you know it cost a lot of
money
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]